when I come back from the video store
with Transporter 2 and we get into like
it's sort of overtly comedic at first
and then it and then it just turns into
like a real relationship melodrama yes
we have that scene transcribed if you
guys want to want to act it out yeah all
right hey uh
where you been
uh what do you mean I was getting the
movie transporter too I know you wanted
to see Predator again but I feel like
you know we've seen that like 30 times
in the last two months and I thought
maybe we could mix things up you know
video store clerk guy said that this
movie was was awesome so
the video store clerk guy I feel like
you you won't stop talking about him
that's a better take huh yeah it was a
good take very sad very real let's use
that one circle is that one oh that one
and I asked him for a movie
recommendation okay yeah and you got one
[Laughter]
foreign